Tapp hey how's it going bro so -
beautiful
welcome back to the Walking Dead episode
2 of season 3 a new frontier ah
that's louder than I expected we played
episode 1 and if you haven't checked it
out yet I highly recommend your doing so
I know what every time people are like
oh you gotta check out these other video
even though you're clearly watching this
one but episode 1 was really strong it
was really good and I think that's just
what this franchise needed was a little
better boost we got new characters that
are interesting and you've scenery and
you Walking Dead like we haven't really
felt before a more advanced unit let's
play I don't know why I even bother
trying to talk like I know [ __ ] cuz I
clearly don't
but Clementine is [ __ ] adorable okay
she's still like too young you know
but she's cute season four she's gonna
be hot thought please let me do the
dishes no it doesn't matter but I care
okay mom crashing here
Crashers claim vicious you're family
besides if they're not clean the right
way if it becomes a big baby about it
all I'm a pro at this point fine to be
an expert relax her if only you weren't
a degenerate gambler - ouch
that's our bad very soon no I know you
don't mind but I won't be here for too
long just you know gotta get back on my
feet a little you're right I don't mind
but David does is that it maybe a little
bit so this is how okay forget I said
that that wasn't for me - he's always
talking about how I'm never around and
then when I'm actually here he acts like
he doesn't know me it's complicated it's
just he loves you you know everybody's
gonna hear his brother he's got an odd
way of showing it so where do you think
you'll go don't know with what happened
I'd be amazed if I could get a job
assistant coaching t-ball you'll land on
your feet
here's hoping I could use a fresh start
no I'll probably just travel around you
know see what's out there want to take
me with you Oh
well Katie come on but you know that's a
bad idea of course I do I'm just messing
around she's married
it's just wise marry they know to a
fresh start I always wanted to go to
Norway what see them Northern Lights
okay I was like why would anyone go to
that [ __ ] I'll still just be here oh
god damn it I got it
[ __ ] quick run underwater Jesus receive
its army glass oh it's gonna be so pissy
about it well David I'm being a little
[ __ ] okay
oh it's so annoying just blame me
my hell buy it I'm the idiot [ __ ] up
right that's true
exactly there you go see much better I
like it what he's wearing
was that no that the top and the bottom
you know a baseball shirt
guys
we'll pull away in the last second or
you're gonna be okay hello
oh [ __ ] no my CEO gave me that and
unless you want to dig up his [ __ ]
corpse he's not gonna give me another
why don't we get an actual dishwater
here we go again then you won't be on my
ass anytime there's a spot on a fork
excuse me if we could even afford a
dishwasher it is just the glass it was
important to me javi a glass we don't
see your ass for a year a year then when
your life goes to [ __ ] we're expected to
drop everything and roll out the red
carpet all for Prince javi and now
you're gonna start telling me how to
talk to my wife that's right really he's
the one standing right there judging me
for something he doesn't understand
we're hitting on our brother I don't
want him like I do
you know what David time for you to open
your eyes Kate's gonna leave your ass
what she told us he okay she said that
wait up wait a minute that's not what I
wanted to say in that scenario what the
[ __ ] told him off means like standing up
for yourself not she's gonna leave you
what the [ __ ] christ no we were
talking about traveling and I just know
God definitely didn't say that I hate
when that happens in glory days then I
want you off my couch and out the door
is it echoing in here I didn't say that
at all either we clear fine
sorry we keep pausing javi that is my
husband we are married in case you
forgot that's for life too bad he's he's
dead now okay
oh [ __ ] I forgot everything that
happened mom this is bad this is real
bad I like how this fight the apocalypse
we kept our fashion sense
baseball with the long arm sleeve
underneath
hey it's jacksepticeye oh no glad I died
take it easy what happened they got away
Oh God
Mariana I don't care have we got Clemmy
that's all we need
oh that's pretty [ __ ] up though
I already dug a grave for her
thank you
I wasn't ready for that you know it
happened sawdust suddenly dude that's a
pretty well sized hole you dug there
Clementine
we'll never forget you
you were good sister the game
and
and like a daughter to me
havi
thank you for staying I think you
probably saved my life
probably not we know she's in the later
episodes but thank you I should have
gone with them
no we fought we slowed them down and now
they'll come back for us right I I don't
know maybe
[Music]
leave the cassette player yeah here on a
sec she carried this around for years
[Music]
fill it up I'm a healthy climate I knew
this
she must be like a master digger level
level hundred digger love a hundred more
I'm sorry I never found you those candy
bars he's deserved just so much more
life you should have been the one
burying me some someday someday far away
[ __ ] man
you did everything you possibly [ __ ] I'm
getting tired of these [ __ ] ass
I hope that's not someone we know dude
why does he look so weird [ __ ] are
you seeis metal is he a metal band or a
see just a zombie zombie
why was he marked the other guys had
this - [ __ ]
what well what's wrong Clem yeah what's
that mean plan like this guys before who
are they please
how much has Clementine been through
Jesus call themselves the new frontier
they used to be decent people now
they're something else
this brand they have it's like an
initiation thing I was kind of stuck in
their camp for a while not by choice it
was bad I'm lucky to be alive
bad hell I got out that's all that
matters
so that's what we saw in the beginning
when Clementine was running away with a
kid cars behind that's something at
least still don't know where it is just
like you always wanted
good I guess we even now claim ya happy
huh heaven I can take you back to
Prescott make sure your family's okay
but then I'm hitting the road suit
yourself
good luck out there Clem thanks javi we
should get back to Prescott
hello she's driving she's the [ __ ]
kid and him
if you think about like so less people
out there wouldn't surely there'd be
plenty of gas around I don't know it's
kind of hard to I just shot up hey guys
what's up it's your back how's Kate she
just came out of surgery
Elinor still with her thank God you best
get over the infirmary
he made it back
[Music]
she asked for you you know I got here as
soon as I could we have a bad habit of
those guys didn't go down without a
fight
and then Mariana
I managed to stabilize her those
bastards did her one favor at least any
lower and that bullet would have torn
her stomach lining as well your boy game
he seems really fierce he wanted to help
so badly he practically forced me to let
him stay that's good but she was
bleeding so much he got overwhelmed so
when's she gonna be up on her feet again
she's stable for now but she's still
bleeding inside if I'm gonna lie to you
it's probably just a matter of time I
know I don't accept that
I can't I've done everything I can for
now they know if you die you turn into a
walker why do they keep her I they're in
the open if they're innocent you mean
when I gave you like pretty upset when
he left this isn't gonna make him feel
any better still I'll track him down
okay so here we are free to roam around
oh sorry
how's she doing not great as well as can
be expected and considering you should
have come back with us your family then
yeah yeah yeah it's always like I'm in
time needed my help back there she could
take care of herself your family they
were the ones who needed help
and something like this do you make a
distinction in the situation no matter
what you snow I'm praying for you all of
you everyone whatever helps you you all
are welcome to stick around and Prescott
if that's what you want
nobody's gonna force you but not gonna
make a decision like that without
talking to Kate so I'd rather check in
with her when she feeling better you
know sure thing let the lady weigh in
first this seems like a nice place
honestly is it besides the you know the
guy that day we got a little that trick
of ruin you know Hey look at those guys
probably up there smoking no smoking out
of pop you know hey your water bottle I
should take that it's not mine but you
know now I can just sweet bottle flips
bet I do them better than jacksepticeye
of course I do
I like the background music it's very
nice flew in a plane just like this to a
baseball game in Arkansas once lifetime
ago doesn't look super sturdy
I like these parts they're so down in
shell let's talk to this guy Conrad
what up Conrad you're hammering up there
you see the kid come through here
blood all over his hands dog look on his
face headed out that way without saying
word if I were you why don't I give him
some space just my advice one parent to
another
he's had a really bad day I can't let
him go off by himself not right now
sorry to hear that
that blood I take it that wasn't his his
stepmoms you got to stay strong for do
whatever it takes
no of my Francine we're in the same
situation I fight like hell anything we
can do to help you out just let me know
I appreciate that your boy stopped all
towards the funky okay now we know where
he is
we're not gonna accident they got to
start farming if they're gonna survive
out in the wild you know they gotta be
able to sustain himself farther than
just scrap food and [ __ ] like that man I
want to spank that ass so good oh great
I can't walk they're awesome I got to
walk away around really really that's
what you want me to do you don't want me
to talk to this handsome fellow over
here he doesn't look like he's faced at
all by this it's got a [ __ ] man bun
going on
[Music]
oh that's the [ __ ] he pointed that
way come on look at me I want to go back
and bury Mariana already later it was
peaceful who could have been peaceful
[Music]
I can't tell you how sorry I am game
sorry about what happened to her sorry
you had to see yeah well sorry thing
gonna bring her back him Kate she needed
me during her surgery she needed my help
I just ran away like a stupid little kid
you stayed long enough to do some good
because of that I'm proud of you you
were there for her as much as you could
be it doesn't count
[Music]
I'm done feeling this way feeling
powerless I can't be some helpless
little boy anymore I need to be a man
just like my dad you need to drop that
be me
he knew how men were supposed to act
you're already a man Gabe I'm not but at
least I know it now next time I'm not
gonna sit back and watch I'm gonna do
something I have to drop it listen Gabe
listen you look stupid orange is not
your collar Gabe why he just teleported
up there what the [ __ ]
these guys are [ __ ] machines like a
Jason from Halloween
[ __ ] hell we might have to leave make
sure Kate's ready you can count on me
oh thanks it is the help what is it it's
a framerate issue does anyone have a
hand grenade oh [ __ ] they got walkers in
to talk knock anyone home I would
literally just spray them [ __ ] he was
one of the men at the junkyard these are
those freaks that brand themselves I
wish we had that to come all the way out
here but unfortunately badger here says
you attacked his man he says you fired
off they shot first
they killed my nice shot a woman in cold
blood
how many of my friends died because of
you huh sounds like a budget he said she
said [ __ ] to me
what the [ __ ] do you want an apology
what I really want is for my good
buddies to be alive again but I don't
think that's too likely is it he needs
to come with us
answer the justice accept his punishment
then they've gotta have laws otherwise
we're no better than the animals go [ __ ]
yourselves you're not getting [ __ ] from
us that gate ain't bulletproof don't
make me prove it back to the matter is
you stole from us you killed some of us
give it up now and get down here I think
they need a little incentive
wait what that Lonnie its Lonnie back a
lot I swear to god that was Lonnie I
don't give a [ __ ] you didn't tell me you
had a hostage don't be okay baby I love
you baby
just just give them what they want
there's no reason this has to get ugly
but we ain't leaving without what we
came for she's innocent in this you
don't have to drag her into our fight I
don't have to but I kind of want to hell
are you doing Bobby please man just just
don't with him
you got to you kill Francie nobody's
giving in to them
you should start shooting him no [ __ ]
way
you killed Francine
fire wrong one a good job friend
La Nina
now
they're standing like in the middle of
the [ __ ] Road it's like well what are
you it's probably better for us if they
go in anyway oh she's got a oh great you
blew the gate open you blew our only
defense oh [ __ ] we don't have to go go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you go ahead
Ram the [ __ ] gate Jesus Christ
well if Odin is referring to me
oh [ __ ] there's walkers in there come on
what can they really do
oh he wants to coddle you you kill eight
every time can you help us hold these
[ __ ] off he literally was right next
to the tear gas that should have
infected him alone hey that was a dead
one
there's I want is golden need that night
chest that was [ __ ] cool
don't worry about it man
what the [ __ ] is that back to the future
let's just use it there's an upper bar
we can try to get 99.9 speed means what
habitat probably don't get back make
attempt before this [ __ ] yeah
well that one's name at East will catch
up
why does he care we're clearly trouble I
realize well [ __ ] this I'm a new
frontier
what a [ __ ] intro Jesus that was the
intro [ __ ] it's been 25 minutes
[ __ ] yeah climate can go to the turtle
truck
not the horse
I can't water
how
how can this happen
[Music]
just climbed somewhere where they can't
not the horse
anything if anything happens to the
horse I will stop playing immediately
okay well speaking of stop playing we
got about 30 minutes left on the last
last part so last part will be up
tomorrow thank you for watching I'm so
excited that you guys are loving these
episodes it makes me really proud and
happy to be doing what I'm doing
so check out episode next one it's here
and I'll see you in the next one
thank you for leaving your like stay
awesome